مساء امريكيه لحل الازمه بين حزبي السلطه
في اقليم كردستان العراق بلقاء منسقي
البيت الابيض للشؤون الشرق الاوسط وشمالي
افريقيا
امن الطاقه في ظل خلافات اربيل وبغداد
ومواضيعه تخص تهريب الدولار الى ايران عبر
مودرن كرديه حدوديه بمحافظه السليمانيه
محذرا من استمرار ذلك التهريب طبعا نحن كح
اذا الديمقراطي كردستاني نرحب بزياره
مبحوث الامريكي الخاص للشرق الاوسط وقد
بحث في هذه الاجتماعات داخليه سياسيه
تتابعه عليه اقليم كردستان داخليا وملفات
العالقه بيننا وبيننا الحكومه اتحاديه
وكانت الزياره زياره ناجحه ومثمره وان شاء
الله نتائج و ااا يعني ستظهر لاحقا في
المستقبل القريب التسريبات تفيد بان
المبعوث الامريكيه تجنب الاجتماع مع
الزعيم حزب الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني
بابل طالباني في مقره بمحافظه السليمانيه
المحاذيه لايران وفضل الاجتماع في اربيل
عاصمه اقليم كردستان العراق جانب الاكبر
كان هو كيفيه العلاقه مع الحكومه
والاتحاديه وانهاء الملفات الخلافيه طبعا
بما في ذلك العلاقه بين الاتحاد هناك قلق
سابق وقلق حتى في هذا اللقاء من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في توصل
العلاقه بين الاتحاد
وخطوات رئيس الحكومه التي ليس لها مبرره
في كيفيه التعامل مع الشركاء السياسيه
ايجابي من الزمان مضى على الدوري الامريكي
لتقارب الكردي الكردي في اقليم كردستان
العراق معايده الحرب الاهليه الكرديه
انذاك واليوم عادت امريكا لتتلافى تكرار
ذلك الاقتتال كون مصالح امريكا وخططها
الاستراتيجيه ربما ستتضرر ان عادت الفوضى
الى كردستان العراق من اربيل احمد
الحمداني العربيه